hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play doorways
okay so I was greeted by an assortment
of rather odd sounds as I walked in here
I gotta say the ambience in this game
especially in this area is absolutely
fantastic I love it I love it a lot okay
so I gotta get back through these traps
here hello excuse me don't don't kill me
okay we're good don't kill me alright
we're good okay hello oh my okay so I
guess I'm not going back that way
hope I don't die okay jeez don't die
don't die don't die don't die okay we're
gonna do die there we are
alright so yep happened there - okay so
whatever I triggered I think I opened
the door to the giant gate and now I got
to get back huh okay don't die don't die
I'm being thoroughly closed off so I
need to not die there's those noises
again a cacophony of wail hello alrighty
then I can go back now can I go through
here Irene I distinctly remember there
being something over here what happened
what happened it just went dark what
happened
I'm so confused wait is there another
side that oh okay I get it I need to go
down another side this game gives me the
heebie-jeebies like okay
ah all right what the hell what does all
that mean what does that mean what I
know what that means
okay there's a Slenderman a circle some
guys fighting over a fork and a birdcage
I guess all right let's just go and
avoid oh I get it
okay things circle thing circle two guys
fighting over a fork birdcage thing
circle Oh God okay two guys fighting
over a fork birdcage clang got it all
right
we're a winner huh winner winner chicken
dinner
oh my god you know it's amazing that
Rick Sunderman fart fork slenderman fork
circle birdcage slenderman fork circle
birdcage slenderman fork oh my goodness
Circle oh good
Slenderman Circle ah gah fork fork
slender fork damn it good there hasn't
been a single monster that's tried to
chase me fork circle birdcage Slenderman
fork circle birdcage
Slenderman Fork circle birdcage
Slenderman Fork
oh my god no okay I can hop over this I
you son of a [ __ ] I'm like sweating
okay I'm sorry it wasn't me that did it
I'm just an innocent bystander in this
horrifying world okay I did it
can I open the gate now do I have to
still go through Slenderman I don't
remember the order Slenderman Fork
circle birdcage slip slender circle fork
birdcage all right slender sir oh why I
had a son circle Thunder circle oh oh
slender slender circle circle fork fork
okay slender slender circle fork fork
Slendy Slendy okay circle fork fork
birdcage okay
all right we got this what the hell how
am I supposed to do that friend e-flat
nee circle fork fork birdcage oh my god
how do they know that works I don't know
that works okay Slendy circle fork
birdcage Fork what no you can't do that
that's stupid
slender circle fork birdcage fork circle
I'm bad at these I'm bad at these
slender slender oh that's not right what
is it wait no no no thunder circle Oh
fork birdcage fork circle yeah I did it
I feel so accomplished for doing
something so silly and stupid
I never expected a puzzle oh okay that's
just a thing that was that thing that I
saw before
no big blurry but can I get through now
to whatever hell awaits me okay
all right then okay boy where what now
why do I keep randomly blinking I keep
blacking out at random points blood
pressure dropping blood sugar is low and
now back to the hellish world
I remember having felt great relief when
I left behind those sinister dungeons
with their dark halls and their whispers
the presence of those accusing tortured
souls was killing me at every step
I didn't do this once in clearing the
tranquility of having found an exit was
interrupted by the sudden notion of my
finding me once again in the dark woods
those haunting shadows were starting to
drive me insane
still something kept me moving forward I
knew I was closer than ever to the place
I needed to find I was determined to
discover the truth whoever was
responsible would pay for the suffering
he caused okay so am i writing these
notes as I'm going along or am i picking
them up finding a journal of someone
else that is really confusing for me
foosh okay back into the lovely woods
which I love so much with all my heart
and kindness sharing an understanding
love it love love love love love these
woods they're my favorite thing of all
the things that I love come on foosh
okay I'm not going in a circle am i
maybe maybe not I have no idea I can
barely see two inches in front of my
room oh no don't give me no don't give
me don't kill me don't kill don't kill
me oh good night little Gilly where am i
where am i what am i doing where am I
going what am i doing where we going
where we going what am i doing where we
going where we go where am i good idea
to you with okay up here okay good
oh good haunted house in the middle of
the woods why wouldn't I go up to that
why wouldn't I do that nice I gonna put
a little I don't wanna I don't wanna I
don't know I don't wanna I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't want
to go
I really don't I'd rather not if that's
okay
good thing it's boarded up good I guess
I can't go ahead good that's great
I seem to now be also walking oh that's
right cuz I can't sprint it's only walk
okay so I guess I can't go in the house
that's good
I didn't want anyway let's go around it
I think I saw pass over here alright
alright forget
oh god that's not any better the
abandoned shed by mouse and sometimes
worse than the house itself great where
am I
what is this this is a dead end what is
going on here it's a dead fricken end
was there something in here that I
needed I don't see anything
okay alright okay alright okay gimme
gimme through I got through before how
am i doing what am I doing with my life
I have no idea there's nothing here it's
just a complete emptiness no place to
light my torch and nothing in this house
okay
is there a way to get on top of the
house apparently not well I'm confused
what am i doing what am i doing I'm so
confused
alrighty then
what is going on wait no I
okay that's locked but wait no maybe I
have something in my him no that's not
what I'm no no don't do that
no go to the inventory no not that I
don't want that torched oh okay I
thought you were turning around to show
me something behind me excuse me very
much okay no do I have anything else in
my inventory apparently not
wow that was a waste of time okay so
this I need to find a key there must
have been a key back in this area back
here it's kind of sometimes kind of hard
to find something amongst the
nothingness so let me try again maybe I
could do it a little better there's
gotta be something down here on the
ground something inconspicuous that I
wouldn't normally see I hear those
things in the darkness something under a
floorboard underneath somewhere I can't
crouch so there I go see his Crouch
there's gotta be something down here
that wouldn't I see no oh there we go
okay got it I knew there had to be
something under there I didn't even see
that all I was doing was clicking
randomly but I guess it paid off hey
random actions pay off in the end
everyone understand that kitties what
have we got no use the key dumbass use
the key there we go why am i excited why
was I so eager to get down here okay
alright I don't like this place Sam I am
I don't like green eggs and ham why is
there power all of a sudden I was just
seen oh oh good
I don't want to be here I don't want to
be here you guys have got to play this
game for yourself did something just
push me seriously you guys have got to
play this game for yourself it's
something about the atmosphere at the
game make sure the volume is cranked up
way high because I've just got the worst
feeling going into this place oh my god
I've just had the worst feeling the
entire time I've played this game
nothing's actually happened that's the
worst part
what Oh Pookie all right i just opened a
freaking door I didn't open a portal
into hell
geez you need to calm down game I'm
taking this one step it I'm taking it
one step at a time okay
there's nothing this is my noises random
noise maybe I could get an actual
flashlight since there seems to be power
here
what was that I heard a freaking
children's song toy thing going on you
can't tell me I didn't hear that
I feel like been in this place hundreds
of times before yeah okay I'm sure this
is my first time here all right until
yesterday the existence of this hideout
is here
we applied engineering all these torture
machines is astounding what type of mind
is that brilliant and at the same time
that twisted that it can design systems
so efficient Indian pain and affliction
okay to go through the function of every
piece of the machines is torture itself
but caring can feel the despair of the
victims while the professor methodically
assembles each part making them watch
making them imagine the pain before
provoking it it sounds like it sucks
just like being in this place to it I
have to follow every step in his
memories as accurately as possible oh
I'm in his memories feel what he feels
was see what he sees and then find him
not only physically but spiritually as
well okay this is the price I have to
pay to get him and make him pay for his
crimes if you say so why don't you just
take a gun and shoot him in the face if
he's so horrible well this add noise it
keeps happening cases I gotta collect
all these I got a reassemble all of his
torture devices are you kidding me is
this some amnesia [ __ ] that I gotta do
why why would I have to do that oh that
is a horrible horrible torture device it
may not seem like much with that is a
really bad one okay all of these are
pretty bad let me let me just say all of
these are pretty horrific oh look here's
one right here
goody goody gumdrops oh they're all here
I didn't notice that before okay good
great come on I'm so happy it's so weird
I swear every to where I turn it's like
a different sound goes off is so creepy
okay so I need to put something in there
good so I gotta go down good I got to go
down all these hallways and try to find
the pieces of the frickin puzzle
seriously what is that I want to know is
that actually doing something or is that
oh god okay this is some amnesia stuff
right here like towards the end with in
the original okay who is this some sort
of oh that's the skullcap for the skull
crusher good great I love that one
excuse me that is a rough way to go the
horrific torture device they think I'm
just assembling all the pieces I should
check that other room again because what
that does is it's a very very slow way
to die
it's um they crush your skull but not to
kill you they just do it tight enough so
that every single touch causes shooting
pain throughout the rest of your body
and it's a very slow methodical painful
way to die is your teeth explode out of
your mouth and your eyeballs squish out
of your eye sockets it's pretty bad
stuff I'm gonna assume that that sound
is actually nothing just gonna assume
what have I gone in here wait that
thought wait a minute no no no no no no
no all right yeah I get it
clang clang okay yeah I did go in there
sorry I'm kind of losing my place this
place freaks me out
okay got all of those let me just
assemble the pieces before I start
slapping them together willy-nilly
I mean seared sincerely this is the most
creeped out I've been without any
monster or stuff this game drips with
atmosphere it's phenomenal okay so that
just leads down in a circle that means
there must be more pieces down here
unless there are more pieces just hiding
in the corners that I can't see which I
would definitely guess is a thing okay
there's another piece I don't know what
that's for but I got it
just randomly clicking hello giant we
love
oh man do they feed him in groin first
and then this mash them up into itty
bitty bits is awful this whole game is
awful or no it's great but oh man this
take out another yay why hot professor
sorry mystery last class
I'll take notes more diligently next
time why am i assembling blocks of wood
why do I need blocks of wood
when does that professor gonna show up
again okay corkscrew type device I
wasn't ready without okay stop it with
the roundabout is I think you're gonna
show him okay there's a lots of pieces
in this room goody goody gumdrops
okay just waiting for the moment okay
wait I have a piece for this one I can
do this let me uh here we go gonna soar
through all my items I've got so many
okay yeah professor sorry could you go
slower I didn't get didn't get that go
back a few taking notes as fast as I can
hold on professor
okay let's see if I have whatever I need
for this okay there's something that
goes in there I don't know why but some
time planks of wood I've got a bunch of
plagues of wood but nothing else way is
that going there really why is that a
thing well why is that a thing that
doesn't make any sense
why is that oh I get it that's the leg
snapper breaker that's the leg breaker I
don't think this is correct but I'm just
gonna throw them in here it's where you
wedge a piece of wood between their legs
hold them firmly in place and then yeah
do that yeah you do that you do that and
it's fun it's fun for the whole family
okay I think the corkscrew goes in here
I know I can just hit I am
why why professor why do you do these
things okay I've only got two more I
think I need to assemble I don't know
what was up with the giant spinning
wheel of death I I don't recall that one
in particular and then this one which I
don't even know where you put something
here now I know you can just put a I
know see this know this oh that poor
lady why why our brother why all right I
guess I got to go back to the big
spinning wheel of death that'll be fun
Oh some Ayane I hear that you can't say
don't you guys hear that right you guys
hear that okay I think I if there's one
looks fully assembled I don't oh there
we go down there at the bottom
I don't know I'm missing a little more
yeah I'm missing something else I think
this one okay yeah I think this one must
go to the spinning wheel of death and
then I got to find another one that I
haven't found it yet why is it so dark
here why is it so dark here why is it so
dark here who was it hurt before maybe
just cuz I did the things but I've got a
feeling that's not wise the thing it was
dark there it wasn't dark before
okay so okay let's go to the spinning
wheel of death try to find wherever the
hell no okay no that's a negatory
ten-four my good buddy okay I don't know
if I can pick up anything while I'm
holding this so this may be working
against me
hello oh this is a skull crusher hang on
there's gotta be some is it some some
something all right
actually I'm way over time so I'm gonna
wrap it up as soon as I find wherever
the hell this goes found a bunch of
stuff here
I guess nine no more all right I'm gonna
figure this out in the next part this is
so so creepy it's just so ah it's hard
to describe it's it's what I have always
said makes a good horror game because
it's very slow and methodical it makes
you feel like there's things that aren't
really there and then there's something
there and that it's not and then it
disappears and then you hear noises out
of the corner of your ears and okay
alright so anyway you gotta play this
game guys it's really really freaky haha
played in a dark room with headphones
you will enjoy crank up that volume so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click DM Jason for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
oh yeah got it
Oh who are you I'm showing buddy Oh
crapped your pants
Barcelona
Oh
oh what the [ __ ] hell Oh get out of
here oh I've been no help
I've no help ice macula like Julian time
let's be mounted 80 BC
we're